[Music]
laughs
welcome back to the true Geordie YouTube
channel now I know I said I wouldn't
talk about Andrew Tate anymore but
unfortunately he's just gotten himself a
lot though and now is one of the most
talked about things on YouTube so it's
basically impossible to avoid a lot of
you because of my interactions with him
which I'm not proud of will probably
think I'm here to Glow oh you got
yourself arrested
but potentially there's six victims or
more here and that's nothing to laugh at
what I want to do in this video is just
look into what he's been accused of look
at the evidence and look at what we know
and then you guys can make your own
Mains up so he was having an argument
with a teenage girl on Twitter because
that's what you do when you're 36 and
the top G apparently like I said I
wasn't going to laugh but that bit I can
laugh at because it's just ridiculous so
Greta thundberg buy her own Twitter bio
is an autistic climate Justice activist
so as you have already seen I'm sure
made a tweet I've got 33 cars my Bugatti
yada yada yada and Greta great I just
responds with please do enlighten me
email me at smalldickenergy galalife.com
this is now one of the most liked Tweets
in history so to say he got destroyed is
is an understatement there and that is
quite funny but it's harmless it's silly
and you think to yourself leave it at
that mate but no so for whatever reason
Andrew couldn't just leave it at that he
had to respond I'm actually mad at Greta
right because she doesn't realize she's
been programmed she doesn't realize
she's a slave of the Matrix enough of
that waffle because this is where it
actually gets interesting the pizza
boxes that he actually acknowledges in
the video give away his location to the
police force who have been looking for
him so Tate was arrested as you're all
away as part of a human trafficking and
rape investigation and according to the
report here in the Daily Mail kept Six
Women under house arrest 24 7 like
prisoners it was alleged last night
officials close to the case said Tate
asked his employees to Shadow his
victims every move forcing them to take
part in online pornographic videos the
abuse was physical and emotional they
were not allowed to leave the house
without security and they were watched
day and night a Romanian judicial source
told the meal they were essentially kept
under house arrest 24 7 like prisoners
they were deprived of their freedom and
followed everywhere the 36 year old was
arrested and his brother Tristan 34
alongside their assistance Georgiana and
Luana at their 600 000 pound Villa in
the Romanian capital Bucharest yesterday
morning the dawn raid by officers from
the city's une organized crime unit was
part of a nine month long investigation
the forward taken by police into a cell
in Bucharest before a court hearing
which authorities are seeking to keep
them in detention for one month which
now has been agreed to although Tate's
lawyers are appealing it prosecutors
allege that Tate recruited the women on
social media platforms and lured them
the Bucharest by falsely professing his
love at and intention to marry them the
tactics are known as the Loverboy method
which is used by criminals to recruit
victims who are suffering from economic
hardship by seducing them with gifts and
Promises of a better life the six
victims were forced to take part in
videos on the adult content platform
only fans we have information based on
what they said on social media that one
of the girls brought in up to 50 000
Euros a month and they were giving no
money from what they earned the women
included an American a moldovan and four
Romanian Nationals the 22 year old who
can't be named for legal reasons had
managed to recover her mobile phone and
call her boyfriend in the US who alerted
the embassy there is some debate on
whether or not it was the pizza box that
gave us the location away and really who
cares the point is is he's been arrested
and who is it who's actually arresting
him well there's a Romanian lawyer on
YouTube because everyone's on footman
YouTube who actually has a bit of
information on the prosecutor behind
gained the investigation into Andrew
Taylor the prosecutor that is leading
the case is actually a safe prosecutor
and he's very well known in Romania for
leading some of the biggest and most
famous cases against anti-mafia for
example he's very well known for
arresting the biggest drug lord in
Romania the man arrested the biggest
drug lord in Romania so they've hardly
got Chief wigger money you know this is
a serious man he's also known for being
one of the toughest prosecutors in
Romania and because of his past
experience and because he received
during his career a lot of death threats
he has 24 7 security assured by the
Special Forces so the guy on the job
took down that many Big Time criminals
he needs security like that says a lot
what we can take from that is he ain't
going to be intimidated by anyone
especially not a man who's teaching how
to become an online Hustler you know I
don't think he's going to be bothered
about Andrew Tate now in my opinion
being that he's very experienced he
would have never arrested him in the
first place if he didn't have enough
evidence to support the case big point
there from the Romanian lawyer here
Stefan lauridan sorry if I've missed
pronounce their name this man is a
serious dude who is not going to have
arrested Andrew Tate with zero evidence
that is very important because when you
look at the online reaction everyone who
has any like for Android is already
saying he's innocent let him go and
we're hearing from a Romania lawyer this
man doesn't play around and if he's
arrested him there's some serious [__]
behind it so after Tate's arrest his
fans were flooding Twitter blaming the
Matrix for his arrest now the Matrix
seems to be a word that Andrew uses for
the powers that be I'm assuming he's not
referring to the great movie in 99
featuring Keanu Reeves big fun and
obviously in that movie you have the
agents and you know just to be clear it
was fictional but he often references
they them in interviews and this is an
example of one video that was tweeted a
lot of times where he quote unquote
predicted his arrest you're gonna try
and put me in jail they're gonna kill me
and I would never kill myself under any
circumstances ever and the reason I say
and I say this people they go but what
can they put you in jail for and I'm
like how ignorant are you in your
ignorance to believe they need a reason
you believe it's fair you believe I can
get a lawyer and prove myself innocent
that's not how it works they decide
you're guilty long before and they find
a reason why and it doesn't matter what
you do about it you will pay the [__]
price it's not fair none of it is every
single system is corrupt there's one or
two possibilities here one possibility
that there's a big conspiracy to stop
Andrew Tate and that the the powers that
be are out to get him the other side of
that is he's predicting it because he
knows fine well he's been up there no
good if I have eight pints of Guinness
on a night out I don't predict on the
night out that I'm gonna wake up with a
hangover the next morning I know it's
coming because I know what I did you
following this man was brushing up
against the authorities for a decade
right he'd had issues for a long time
and he was raided back in April for this
very thing so him then later on going on
about getting arrested when he knows
they're looking into him as if he's some
sort of Nostradamus and then his fans
like he called it he called it again I'm
not saying he's guilty but come on use
your [__] head could it be that he
may be aware of some [__] now this video
was taken the week of Andrew Tate's
arrest like literally seven days
beforehand and the answer to all things
in life is to take absolutely not her
self-accountability for all the good and
all the bad you must look at yourself
and realize everything good that
happened in your life is your fault and
everything bad that happens in your life
is completely your fault and without
having that high degree of absolute
accountability
it doesn't matter even if it rains
outside I blame myself because I didn't
have to be in London right I could have
gone I could have stayed in Dubai so
that's Tate saying he believes that
always taking accountability now let's
look at him when he got arrested The
Matrix has attacked me in terms of
taking accountability like claimed he
does putting everything on The Matrix
it's not really that is it don't blame
it on sunshine don't blame it on
moonlight blame it on the Matrix I don't
even know what to say anymore this is
just so weird man we're talking about a
movie made in 99 here Neo was getting
done for cyber crimes right because he
was hacking into NASA and [__] you ain't
kneel me surely if the Matrix wanted to
get him that bad they could have just
started their own podcast and invited
them on because this man will go on any
podcast who will have him and I'll say
this again I don't know if this guy is
Gilly what we do know is he said a lot
of things in the past in relation to his
webcam business to the way he treats
women and we're going to look into that
now and see how that lines up between
what he's been accused of the beginning
of it was I messaged my six girlfriends
and told them they're all coming to live
with me and I had a job for them in
London
uh two of them wouldn't come four of
them agreed and I was like we're gonna
make money a bunch of money you're gonna
live with me just to be clear I've heard
this story a couple of times and both
times the numbers change we'll put it
down to a rusty memory I've been with
you all I'm starting a webcam business
I'm Gonna Get Rich some of you are going
to come with me to the top of the
mountain or if you're pissed off you can
[__] fly home which is very matter of
fact to the point because I needed money
at this point now I have not agreed to
take another fight I need money now just
an idea maybe just get a job like other
hard-working people do but so I cut down
to like a special forces team of around
eight girls and that's where I made my
most money when I had four girlfriends
my brother had four girlfriends me my
brother eight women living in one house
he's established the business model here
he has four girlfriends girlfriends his
brother has four girlfriends that's how
they did it and in this clip Tate says
that he had an altercation with a woman
who was working with him oh yeah and
then I had one girl and she got too
drunk one day and she threw up in my
apartment I told her to clean up she
refused to clean up start being an idiot
so I took her stuff throughout the
window seems like a fairly reasonable
course of action for someone who is
working with you you know and she was my
biggest earning girl she made me on her
own maybe twenty five thousand dollars a
month oh [__] so I didn't want to fire
her and she knew I didn't want to fire
her which is more reason why I had to
fire her ass
so I was like all right cool you want to
be a gangster right you're a gangster
got her [__] we're like high up like
here it was just out the window got hurt
by her two arms and marched her out the
door locked the door end of it okay so
he he admits he he put his hands on uh
he doesn't say he hit us but he he frog
mulched her out the [__] door she
starts texting me texting me you owe me
my last month's wages you owe me my
money give me my money did I text her
back I ain't paying you nothing you
threw up my blah
she went to the police oh [__] and told
the police I hit her so let's just get
this straight this was his top earning
goal and she threw up refused to clean
it up was mouthing off he threw her
stuff out the window for that frog
marched her out she then goes to the
police and says he hit me this just
doesn't make sense to me you know this
was your best earning employee you don't
just get rid of them over something
small like throwing up and then they
don't just accuse you of hitting them
this is a very bizarre story immediately
I heard the door boom boom boom and I
don't know how I knew I just knew it was
police probably because the shouted
police it's usually a giveaway I've done
some things when I had to pay the bills
right so I was a bit like ah what's this
going to be so I like flushed my phone
down the toilet quickly
I'm coming I'm coming I was like who are
you they're like you're under arrest for
a suspicion of assault of this dumb hoe
bear in mind that this girl would have
been a girlfriend
uh
uh yeah they kept me in a Cell for a day
and a half they sent officers to raid my
house took all my electronics took all
my phones on my laptops went through my
entire personal life found 11 new things
to raise charges against me for it's
unrelated because the original case got
dropped because she had no evidence and
she was lying because all the other
girls in the house went to um
okay so according to him the other girls
told the police he was innocent now
logically if he gets sent to prison they
all lose their income too because this
man is the one who's keeping it all
together he's the glue of the situation
there's a very good reason for them to
cover for him that doesn't mean he's
guilty but this whole story it doesn't
not only does it not add up it just
doesn't sound good in any way so this is
what he said when asked about his girl
doing only funds I wouldn't I wouldn't
even mind my girl doing only fans as
long as I kept all the money
I wouldn't give a [__] if I had a girl
who said I want to do only fans I'm like
cool go for it let me know how much
money we make you're keeping all of it
though
yes she's mine 100 you're keeping all
profits I mean I might let her buy us
some shoes or something just based on
this one clip alone you could tell he
does not view women as people they are
property like slaves and that's the way
he uses them he might be nice to them he
might be nasty of them I don't [__]
know but by his own words
they are there to make him money and
that money is all his but all in all I
mean goes into my bank and I might gift
her something depending if she's been
good that month but she's my she's my
property so she's selling my property
like if we're gonna rent out my house
then I get the money right you're my
chick you're my property you're gonna
sell pictures of my property Cool
where's my money so if there's any
doubts left there uh Andrew does not
look at women like people you were there
to be rented out to make me money but
again that doesn't necessarily mean he's
guilty now some of you might wonder why
Andrew chose Romania of all places to
live well he's explained it in a helpful
little video for her this is probably 14
of the reason I moved to Romania because
in Eastern Europe none of this garbage
flies if you don't know the police and
say he raped me back in 1988 because we
should have done something about it then
if you're on a place to stay right
yesterday okay if you've got physical
evidence or is there CCTV proof where'd
it happen Okay let's go interview him
right now and if it wasn't really right
oh we went to the club we got drunk she
agreed to go back to my house we started
having sex and then we carried on having
sex and then we had sex and she didn't
say anything wrong and then she texted
me afterwards and I didn't text back and
now she's saying I raped her the police
would be like okay she's an idiot bye
but no not in the West in the west you
can tell them that exact story you're
still [__] you're [__] in the west
when people say why didn't Romania and I
explain my five reasons one of them is
the metoo era think oh well you're a
rapist I say no I'm a [__] rapist but
I like the idea of being able to just
say to do what I want I like being free
okay let me just stop him right there
they go oh but you're a rapist he says
no I'm not a [__] rapist I just like
the idea of being able to do what I want
the math isn't nothing here what what
the [__] are we even discussing this for
with this guy why is this even coming up
if you're not a rapist why is this even
a thing do you know what I'm thinking
about where I might like to live you
know in the future I think about the
weather you know I think about
properties I don't think about where's
the best place to get away with rape
it's just not on the radar but for this
guy 40 of the reason apparently at best
this is [__] weird at best okay so
remember and Andrew I found his old
website which has since been changed uh
you might realize why once we start
reading it why am I an expert on all
male female interactions I've been
running the webcam studio for nearly a
decade I've had over 75 girls work for
me and my business model is different
than 99 of webcam Studio owners over 50
percent of my employees were actually my
girlfriend at the time of all my
girlfriends none were in the adult
entertainment industry before they met
me well well done you've uh you've
really introduced them to the good life
I really don't think this man
understands what the word girlfriend
actually means just to be clear my job
was to get women to fall in love with me
it's not really a job though is it
literally that was my job my job was to
meet a girl go on a few dates sleep with
her test if she's quality whatever that
means get her to fall in love with me to
where she'd do anything I say and then
get her on a webcam so we could become
rich together whether you agree or
disagree with what I did with their
loyalty submission and love for me
doesn't matter the courts might disagree
on that I learned the most efficient way
to meet girls get them through the
dating process get them to bed test that
they're a good girl or not I wonder what
this test includes do you get them in
the bed and you start passing them forms
that I've written this up so if you
could just fill in the yeah cross tick
wherever okay it's a weird guy and then
I begin the process of them falling
deeper and deeper in love that is my
skill to extremely efficiently get women
in love with me that's it and no one
else on the Internet is teaching this no
one as you can see all these pictures of
him in bed with women and whatever do
you have a girl who completely trusts
your decisions will do anything you say
and loves you deeply yes or no if the
answer is yes my advice just to be clear
you might not want to listen to it just
look after her maybe take her out uh
share a good time make her feel loved
maybe Mario have some kids live happily
ever after just we'll just look at what
Andrew says they'll wait there if your
answer is yes then I guarantee 90 of you
are lying to yourselves apparently I was
wrong uh okay and ask yourselves if
you've ever tested your belief if the
answer is no you're missing out on one
of life's great Pleasures I'm assuming
by that he means by putting your lovely
girlfriend on the internet for other men
to wank off to I'm not sure if that's
one of life's greatest Pleasures I've
I've never done it so how would I know
maybe I'm missing out on something great
if you're too busy to get one good the
PHD system was made for you if you're
happy touching your own dick this power
is not for you I cannot believe this man
has literally got people like buying
this like it's [__] mental so what
exactly do you get with the PHD program
I will teach you how to text women how
to build your social medias to pick up
women best first dates to bring women on
best follow-up dates how to approach
women the framework that all male female
interactions are based on how to test to
save a woman is high quality my opening
lines how to get women into bed I am the
most capable man in the world to teach
you this power I have a warning there's
responsibility when you have someone
completely loyal to you I've had some
girls for over a decade
when someone gives themselves to you
their life path is in your hands be wise
look like Spider-Man once said with
great power comes great responsibility
and when you have that power you put the
girls on the webcam get the money for
you actually I don't remember that one
in Spider-Man it's funny that so in
regards to human trafficking and people
smuggling the term lover boys uh we've
got a government definition for it so
you can judge whether or not Andrew fits
the description of what is a Loverboy
human trafficker lover boy or raw me or
pimps or human traffickers who usually
operate by trying to make young girls or
boys fall in love with them sometimes
they manipulate young people in other
ways once they have victims Under the
Influence they exploit them for instance
in the sex industry like webcoming
traditionally a lover boy seduces young
vulnerable girls over a lengthy period
of time in order to exploit them
sexually later on the internet and
social media are playing an increasing
role in this phenom phenomenon for
instance social media provide lover boys
with much greater scope for establishing
contact with victims and gathering
information about vulnerable boys and
girls this makes it easier for them to
force their young victims into the sex
industry so does that sound like the
method that Andrew Tate used on his own
website I'd rather not say you know I'd
rather you lot be the judge of it here
is Andrew Tate sitting in the back of
the police van looking a little cold not
quite as luxurious as the Bugatti so
these two women uh as you'll see right
here give us a nice little smile are
known as Andrew's two angels Georgiana
and Luana and um they played quite an
interesting role in this by the looks of
it these are a better quality
photographs uh Andrew might have taken
himself who knows of the two women in
question now they were hauled into
custody accused of enslaving the
Romanian and moldovan women to make sex
films as well as traffic and women to
the UK and the US for wealthy clients
this might be more than just the web
coming you know this might be arranging
people to meet some of these victims in
question one of them was a former
Romanian police officer and I know that
is an American citizen who is rumored to
have dated Andrew Tate for almost a year
the fact that one of them is a former
police officer wow imagine the Intel
that she will have on how to avoid the
police and also just what that means for
this entire case the pair dubtate angels
are accused of helping coerce and
control at least six women to take part
in online pornographic videos and the
operation was allegedly kept running
smoothly with the aid of these two women
now police saw said the women
financially benefited and led a
fantastic life before they fall from
grace of course they would have done and
think about their age 32 and 28 if
they're in charge they're going to be
older than a lot of these young girls
who are getting involved in this one of
them was a former police officer she's
going to know exactly how to intimidate
people and keep control of a situation
she's perfect so according to this
article these women were a very
important part of this because they made
sure that the women being held against
their will did exactly as they were told
and as it says here they lived a
fantastic life which was not keeping
with a real financial position so the
money that they were spending does not
add up to what they were doing so why
were they getting paid so much money so
if they say it's all true then these two
angels were basically acting as The
Galleon Maxwell for Andrew you know like
Colleen used to be the go between uh
between Jeffrey Epstein and his victims
so that he didn't have to get his hands
dirty he wouldn't have to always be the
one to make the approach he could keep
she could keep them in line she'd give
them a warning so that's basically what
these women would be doing again if this
is true and later in this article
there's also a few captions from women
who've now come out and said yeah he
messaged me he was really nice he became
controlling and then he started telling
me what to do saying I should obey him
these again could be false it could be
women just trying to get attention on
social media but it's probably worth
mentioning there is a video of Andrew
Tate striking a woman during what he
claimed was play
um let's see if you agree I said when I
said tell the camera
did I say the word
so I'll stop the video there because
that was a hell of a slap now again he
denies that this is serious he said it's
it's play she's wearing lingerie which
kind of leads into him saying that this
is some sort of kinky game but that was
that was a bad slap the clip I've
actually found has another guy actually
commenting on it and I'll I'll let you
listen to what he thinks so he's
breaking a [__] right here this is pimp
tactics he's getting them on such egg
shells that they will evacuate and do
exactly what he says you can call it a
fetish all you want it's not a [__]
fetish it's how you break a [__] this
is a [__] who works under him for money
all right and he's and he beats her and
then he gets her down and he beats her
with a belt okay
look at the camera did I say listen
this [__] is going on Tucker
Carlson all right
did I say it
all right so now she's crying he's
beating her with a belt she is [__]
crying as well this and that's where
you're like okay if if you were getting
off on this as the girl why would you be
sobbing like that I'm really trying to
remain like is is balanced as I can but
this is insanity he did this with other
men in the room he videotaped it and
then he broadcasted it and told that's
how you handle your horse his brother
from what we are led to believe is the
one holding the camera again his brother
and him
were the ones arrested for the for for
allegedly the human trafficking the
abuse and all of that now the girl in
question has done a video claiming she
was fine with it I just wanted to say
something about the video that's been
released recently about me and my
ex-boyfriend Andrew Tate Andrew is my
still great friend what you guys saw on
the video it's just what we used to do
it was just pure game he's a great guy
he will never hurt anyone she herself is
saying it was a game when you hear her
sobbing and and being slapped in the
face that hard it's really hard for me
to connect these dots and and say that
she is right in what she's saying what I
do know on Andrew Tate's final thoughts
of his website he said there's a
responsibility when you have someone
completely loyal to you I've had some
girls for over a decade we don't know if
this woman is still under some sort of
Illusion that there's a relationship
there or whatever and there is also a
chance that she might be just saying
this of our own free will it just
doesn't look good
in any way shape or form so since I
recorded this video something else has
actually come out on vice.com about
Andrew Tate because two women have told
Vice they were violently abused one
being raped the other one repeatedly
strangled by Andrew Tate and that the UK
police and Crown prosecution service
mishandled their case basically the
police took four years to pass their
investigation to the crown prosecution
service whose job involves assessing
whether there's a realistic possibility
of conviction at which point the CPS
declined the prosecute now again that
does not mean he is guilty it does not
mean he is Innocent but let's watch the
video and see what the woman had to say
we were just sitting on the bed and
Andrew punched me in my arm I went to
the bathroom and cried it really really
hurt to have someone just hit me in the
arm for no reason I was very confused
sorry
sorry I don't want to cry but as soon as
he handed me my money I soon forgot
about him hitting me and everything else
and it was just like wow I've got all
this money now like
he would just pay me a flat fee of 15
pounds an hour which back then was
fantastic when the girl says back then
she's meaning uh in 2015 when these
accusations were originally brought up
again this was pre Andrew Tate being
globally known there was no clout
chasing from her in 2015 and agitate had
no clue and she's still at this day
hiding her identity so this isn't
someone just looking to be a celebrity
off the back of Andrew Tate whether you
believe her or not that's up to you but
I just think it's important to recognize
that Andrew would call us lazy hose I
saw him
smack girls with a belt because she
wanted a lion he used to he used to
strangle was
there was another time when he came into
the bedroom me and the other girl we
would sleep in the same bed with Andrew
but at this time the girl had a partner
so she was not interested in Andrew at
all and I had gone to the shower I came
back and I noticed he was
I saw him raping her
and um
I don't know about you love but this is
difficult to listen to you know this
girl was 20 years old when she met this
guy and you know you're trying to make
extra money because minimum wage is the
option so you're doing the web coming
and trying to bring in more money and
then this ends up being what she says
was her reality and the emotions feel
very real in our voice when and Andrew
was arrested we were taken in for a
proper interview
and it kind of just got left I would
send emails asking them to update I'd
hear nothing back
when we reached out to hartfordshire
police about this they had this to say
we acknowledge that there were some
delays to the investigation four [__]
Year's worth Jesus Christ this was
addressed at the time and apologies were
made oh it's all right because the
police apologized so it's fine don't
worry about it you witnessed the rape
occurring did that not count as evidence
for them no and they openly said it's
really really difficult to prove rape
there are multiple women given their
accounts here this is just one one woman
who they've interviewed but the other
woman has also backed her up obviously
police officers have difficult jobs and
it's not always easy just to prove
something even when you have eyewitness
accounts Etc but it's very disappointing
here that this these allegations were
made and and yet they just attract them
like they weren't important like four
years of waiting is staggering and time
is of the essence in a lot of these kind
of cases the other woman who was the one
who was raped also gave a statement to
Vice who said I hope and pray is finally
arrested for his disgusting abuse and
crimes against young women and I can
finally exist without having to see and
hear the person who degraded me and
raped me all the internet and again I
can't say whether or not Tate is guilty
or Innocent but the amount of
information out there linking him with
this kind of behavior is staggering so
to try and round this up I mean some of
his fans out there believe that this is
just the Matrix the government they're
out to get him you know and I think
about people who've really pushed the
government people like Alex Jones who
literally claimed 911 was an inside job
for 20 years and is still out here doing
videos with Kanye West Edward Snowden
who leaked classified documents and I
was doing podcasts with Joe Rogan people
who really [__] push the government
you know Andrew Tate is nothing more
than an Entertainer who's on every
[__] podcast who will have him on you
know he's a bit of a celebrity but to
insinuate that the reason he's being
prosecuted by authorities is down to him
challenging the mainstream media I think
is so laughable in terms of whether he's
guilty or not again I don't know but the
man's been accused of something very
very serious things like human
trafficking and rape these charges carry
10 to 20 years and his tweet from prison
you know I've watched Netflix
documentaries where Syria killers and
they're like they don't acknowledge
anything to do with what they're accused
of and they speak about themselves in a
way that's delusional listen to this
tweet I was made for battle a warrior of
the light my enemies hope to attack me
with lies they tried to destroy the
family unit they tried to silence any
loud opposition I refuse to leave fellow
men in the dark someone needs to show
them the light who better than Tate
you've been arrested for [__] human
trafficking here this is the ramblings
of an absolute narcissistic lunatic to
me but to put that tweet out when that's
what you've been accused of
subsequently mental so I'll leave it at
that
um obviously his Defenders will be there
in the comments battling hard defending
the soldier of the light but hopefully
some of you Common Sense folk out there
will have your own minds uh to make up
we'll see what happens I'm sure you'll
probably get out uh because the guy's
got a lot of money and whatever happens
I just hope that there's Justice and
that uh if there are if there are
victims out there that they are looked
after don't forget to hit the like
button subscribe thanks for watching and
I'll see you later
[Music]